police departments Nationwide have been
struggling with this shortage and
retainment for years now many of them
say since the beginning of the pandemic
but for Nevada State Police here it's
been ongoing for decades and with less
Troopers out on the roads officials say
the state needs to pay up for the sake
of drivers
did you ever see anything like that when
you worked there no no there are far
more than that even when I was on back
in the 90s former State Police Trooper
Scott Behringer hearing about recent
Staffing in his former Department
multiple weekends seen only four
Troopers patrolling a shift 12 to 14 is
considered fully staff leaving response
times reaching highs of 40 minutes it's
so dangerous oh my God bearing your
Patrol these same roads through the 90s
to the mid-2000s the problems then seem
to match the problems now not enough pay
to keep Troopers interested to stay
Personnel getting the basic training
before moving on when you're just the
stepping stone for a lot of the other
agencies it certainly doesn't serve you
earlier this year 8 news now
investigators revealed that starting pay
begins at 55 000 Metro Police can start
at 81 000. Henderson Police a hundred
thousand 112 Troopers have already left
the state department in 2022 pay and
benefits Nevada police union
representative Wayne dice saying the
remaining Troopers are burnt out and
with 65 more Troopers needed for a full
120 staff load he says action is needed
now before it's too late it can be fixed
right now by the governor but he's
choosing not to fix the problem I know I
have union members that are going to
leave prior to session
now he's talking about the next state
legislative session this January about
three months out where it's anticipated
they'll touch upon or at least address
this Staffing Crunch and the union
representative ads the last significant
pay raise they saw over 15 years ago in
2006. reporting live near Decatur and
sunset Ryan Matthey 8 News Now